On dit souvent que l'on peut apprendre beaucoup d'une personne
en regardant ce qu'il y a dans sa bibliothèque.
Que ma bibliothèque dit-elle de moi ?
Eh bien, quand je me suis posée cette question il y a quelques années,
j'ai fait une découverte alarmante.
Je m'étais toujours considérée comme une personne
cosmopolite et assez cultivée.
Mais ma bibliothèque racontait plutôt une autre histoire.
Pratiquement tous les titres étaient
d'auteurs britanniques ou américains,
et il n'y avait presque aucune traduction.
En découvrant ce gouffre dans mes lectures,
j'ai eu un choc.
Et en y pensant, cela me semblait vraiment honteux.
Je savais qu'il devait y avoir un tas d'histoires fabuleuses ailleurs,
d'auteurs écrivant dans une autre langue que l'anglais.
Et cela me semblait vraiment triste de penser que mes habitudes de lecture
faisaient que je ne les découvrirais sûrement jamais.
Alors, j'ai décidé de m'imposer
un programme intensif de lecture mondiale.
2012 devait être une année très internationale pour le Royaume-Uni :
c'était l'année des Jeux Olympiques à Londres.
Alors, j'ai décidé de profiter de cette occasion
pour essayer de lire un roman, une nouvelle,
ou un mémoire de chaque pays du monde.
Et je l'ai fait.
Et c'était vraiment passionnant
et j'ai appris des choses remarquables
et créé des contacts merveilleux
que je veux partager avec vous aujourd'hui.
Mais ça a commencé par quelques problèmes techniques.
Après avoir trouvé laquelle des nombreuses listes de pays
utiliser pour mon projet,
j'ai fini par choisir une liste de nations méconnues,
à laquelle j'ai ajouté Taiwan,
ce qui m'a donné un total de 196 pays.
Et après avoir trouvé comment lire et commenter
environ 4 livres par semaine,
en travaillant 5 jours par semaine,
j'ai alors réalisé que je ne pourrais peut-être pas trouver
des livres de chaque pays traduits en anglais.
Seulement 4,5% des travaux littéraires publiés
chaque année au Royaume-Uni sont des traductions,
et les chiffres sont similaires pour la plupart des pays anglophones.
Même si la proportion des publications traduites
est bien plus importante dans beaucoup d'autres pays.
4,5% est suffisant pour commencer,
mais ce que ce chiffre ne dit pas,
c'est que beaucoup de ces livres viennent de pays
qui ont un réseau de publication solide
et où beaucoup de professionnels vendent d'abord leurs œuvres
à des éditeurs anglophones.
Donc par exemple, même si plus de 100 livres sont traduits du français
et publiés au Royaume-Uni chaque année,
la plupart d'entre eux viendront de pays comme la France ou la Suisse.
L'Afrique francophone, par contre,
est rarement retenue.
Le résultat est qu'il y a en fait beaucoup de nations
qui ne sont pas ou peu représentées
dans la littérature traduite en anglais.
Ces livres restent inconnus aux lecteurs
de la langue la plus publiée au monde.
Mais quand il fallu commencer à lire le monde,
la plus grande difficulté pour moi
était de ne pas savoir par où commencer.
D'avoir passé ma vie à lire presque exclusivement des livres
britanniques ou américains,
je n'avais aucune idée comment trouver des histoires
et les choisir parmi les autres du reste du monde.
Je ne pouvais pas vous dire comment obtenir une histoire de Swaziland.
Je ne connaissais aucun bon roman de Namibie.
Inutile de le cacher -
j'étais une xénophobe ignorante en littérature.
Alors, comment allais-je pouvoir lire le monde ?
J'allais devoir demander de l'aide.
Alors, en Octobre 2011, j'ai commencé mon blog,
ayearofreadingtheworld.com,
et j'ai posté une demande en ligne.
J'ai expliqué qui j'étais,
combien mes lectures avaient été limitées,
et j'ai demandé à tous ceux qui le souhaitaient
de laisser un message sur ce que je pouvais lire
d'autres endroits de la planète.
Alors, je n'avais aucune idée si cela intéresserait quelqu'un,
mais quelques heures après cet appel,
des gens ont commencé à me contacter.
Au début, c'était des amis et des collègues.
Puis ce furent des amis d'amis.
Et très vite, ce furent des inconnus.
4 jours après avoir mis cet appel en ligne,
j'ai reçu un message d'une femme appelée Rafidah de Kuala Lumpur.
Elle disait aimer l'idée de mon projet, et me demandait
si elle pouvait aller dans une librairie anglophone là-bas,
choisir un livre malaisien et me l'envoyer ?
J'ai accepté avec enthousiasme,
et quelques semaines plus tard,
un colis est arrivé contenant pas un, mais 2 livres -
le choix de Rafidah de Malaisie,
et un livre de Singapour qu'elle avait aussi choisi pour moi.
Alors là, à ce moment, j'étais ébahie
qu'une étrangère à plus de 9 600km
en fasse autant pour aider quelqu'un
qu'elle ne rencontrera probablement jamais.
Mais la gentillesse de Rafidah s'est avérée être le modèle de cette année.
Plusieurs fois, des gens sont sortis des sentiers battus pour m'aider.
Certains ont fait des recherches pour moi,
et d'autres des détours pendant leurs vacances ou déplacements
pour aller dans des librairies pour moi.
Au final, si vous voulez lire le monde,
si vous voulez le rencontrer avec un esprit ouvert,
le monde vous aidera.
Quand je suis allée dans les pays
avec pas ou peu d'ouvrages disponibles en anglais,
les gens allaient encore plus loin.
Des livres sont arrivés de sources surprenantes.
Ma lecture du Panama, par exemple, est venue grâce à une conversation
que j'ai eue sur le compte Twitter du Canal du Panama.
Oui, le Canal du Panama a un compte Twitter.
Et quand j'y ai tweeté mon projet,
ils m'ont suggéré que je pourrais essayer de me procurer l'ouvrage
d'un auteur Panamien Juan David Morgan.
J'ai trouvé le site de Morgan et lui ai envoyé un message,
lui demandant si un de ses romans en espagnol
avait été traduit en anglais.
Et il a dit que rien n'avait été publié,
mais qu'il avait une traduction non-publiée
de son roman « Le Cheval d'Or ».
Il l'a envoyée par courriel,
me permettant de devenir l'une des premières personnes
à lire ce livre en anglais.
Morgan n'a pas été le seul écrivain
à partager son travail avec moi de cette façon.
De la Suède à Palau,
écrivains et traducteurs m'ont envoyé des livres auto-publiés
et des manuscrits de leurs livres non-publiés
qui n'ont pas été retenus par des éditeurs anglophones
ou qui n'étaient plus disponibles, me donnant le privilège
de mettre un pied dans de remarquables mondes imaginaires.
J'ai lu, par exemple,
un récit sur le roi Sud Africain Ngungunhane, qui menait la resistance
contre les Portugais au 19ème siècle ;
et sur les rituels de mariage dans un village reculé
sur les côtes de la mer Caspienne au Turkménistan.
J'ai trouvé la réponse du Koweït à Bridget Jones.
( Rires )
Et j'ai lu un livre à propos d'une orgie dans un arbre en Angola.
Mais peut-être que l'exemple le plus incroyable de l'implication de ces gens
prêts à m'aider à lire le monde,
est venu à la fin de ma quête,
quand j'ai essayé de trouver un livre écrit en portugais,
provenant de la petite île africaine de São Tomé et Príncipe.
Après avoir passé plusieurs mois à tout essayer pour trouver
un livre de ce pays traduit en anglais,
il semblait que la seule option qui me restait était
de faire traduire un livre spécialement pour moi.
Là, je doutais vraiment
que quelqu'un veuille bien m'aider avec cela,
et donne de son temps pour ça.
Mais, après une semaine de recherches sur Twitter et Facebook
de personnes parlant portugais,
j'ai eu plus de personnes impliquées dans le projet qu'il n'en fallait,
y compris Margaret Jull Costa, une référence dans son domaine,
qui a traduit l'ouvrage du gagnant du Prix Nobel José Saramago.
Avec 9 bénévoles,
j'ai trouvé un livre d'un auteur de São Tomé
dont j'ai pu acheter assez d'exemplaires sur le net.
En voilà un.
Et j'ai envoyé une copie à chacun de ces bénévoles.
Chacun s'est chargé de quelques-unes des nouvelles de ce recueil,
puis, comme promis, ils m'ont envoyé leurs traductions,
et en 6 semaines, j'ai eu l'intégralité du livre.
Dans ce cas, comme j'ai pu souvent le voir durant cette année de lecture,
mon ignorance et ma compréhension de mes limites
sont devenues une grande opportunité.
A propos de São Tomé et Príncipe,
ç'a été l'occasion non seulement d'apprendre quelque chose de nouveau
et de découvrir d'autres sortes de recueils,
mais aussi de rassembler un groupe de personnes
pour permettre un travail de créativité commun.
Mes faiblesses sont devenues la force du projet.
Les livres que j'ai lus cette année m'ont ouvert les yeux sur beaucoup de choses.
Comme ceux qui aiment lire le savent,
les livres ont un pouvoir extraordinaire de vous sortir de vous-même
et d'entrer dans un autre esprit,
comme si, pour un moment,
vous observiez le monde avec les yeux d'un autre.
Cela peut être une expérience inconfortable,
surtout si vous lisez un livre
d'une culture qui a des valeurs très différentes des vôtres.
Mais cela peut être également un réel enrichissement.
Lutter avec des idées inhabituelles peut aider à clarifier vos propres pensées.
Et cela peut aussi vous montrer les zones d'ombre
de la façon dont vous avez pu regarder le monde.
Quand j'ai repensé à la littérature anglophone
avec laquelle j'ai grandi, par exemple,
j'ai commencé à voir combien elle était limitée,
comparée à la richesse que le monde a à offrir.
Au fur et à mesure que les pages tournaient,
quelque chose d'autre est arrivé.
Petit à petit, cette longue liste de pays
avec laquelle j'ai commencé l'année s'est transformée,
d'une liste de noms de lieux académique, plutôt morne,
en des entités vivantes.
Maintenant, je ne veux pas dire qu'il est possible
de se faire une idée d'un pays en lisant simplement un livre.
Mais en cumulant les histoires que j'ai lu cette année-là,
je me suis rapprochée plus que jamais
de la richesse, de la diversité et de la complexité de notre merveilleuse planète.
C'était comme si les histoires du monde
et les gens qui se sont relayés pour m'aider à les lire
l'avaient rendu vivant pour moi.
Aujourd'hui, lorsque je regarde ma bibliothèque
ou considère les ouvrages sur ma liseuse,
cela me raconte une autre histoire.
C'est l'histoire du pouvoir que les livres ont de nous connecter
au-delà des différends culturels, sociaux, géographiques, politiques, religieux.
C'est l'histoire du potentiel que les Hommes ont en travaillant ensemble.
Et, c'est un témoignage
de l'époque extraordinaire dans laquelle nous vivons, où, grâce à internet,
il est plus facile que jamais
pour un étranger de partager une histoire, une vision du monde, un livre
avec quelqu'un qu'il ne rencontrera jamais, de l'autre coté de la planète.
J'espère que c'est une histoire que je vais lire longtemps encore.
J'espère que beaucoup me rejoindront.
Si nous lisons de façon plus ouverte, il y aura plus d'intérêt
pour les éditeurs à traduire plus de livres,
et nous en serons tous plus riches.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)